well the defense secretary and as of
this morning Liz trust supporter Ben
Wallace joins me in the studio now so
you've come out and said that you're
going to back Liz truss why did you keep
that to yourself for so long were you
just waiting to see who was more likely
to win first of all I came out to
announce today we're going to do a wrap
around child care for you know free wrap
around child care for all the men and
women of the Armed Forces up to the age
of 11 for their children so that's a a
big 1.4 billion pound effort to help
alleviate their cost of living as they
serve our nation so that's that's the
policy announcement today that's why
we're doing the media round but look
look on the on Liz trust and my support
for her is you know I thought what I
would do at the beginning of this
contest is stand back I'm the sexual
safe defense I want to find a candidate
that's going to do right by the
department and and recognize that the
threats we face every day are very real
and are growing and that they need to be
funded properly we can't just sort of
pretend they will go away by themselves
so you know I looked at their
performances I looked at them on the
hustings but I also know them both I've
been in cabinet for two years with both
the chancellor and indeed Liz truss and
so you know it's important for me to to
work out who I thought was the right
person to take us forward so you know I
know Liz she's very straight she's
authentic what you see is what you get
but also she has been very consistent in
the support for defense and security she
reads the same intelligence reports I do
so I felt it was the right person to
back well yes she has been supportive in
fact she's promised an increase in
defense spending to three percent of GDP
but that's going to cost between 20 and
25 billion pounds isn't it she's also
promising more than 30 billion pounds in
tax cuts she's promising to match NHS
spending she's promising to increase
spending on Border controls on the
Northern Powerhouse I mean if she was
straight talking talking and authentic
wouldn't she spell out exactly how she's
going to pay for all of that she has so
first of all the defense spending
increase that is by 2030. that is saying
that we need to grow the defense budget
to be on a three percent of GDP by 2030
we're currently declining we are we are
forecast around 2026 to go below two
percent of GDP taking us from being the
leader in Europe to down to about eighth
in European defense spending which would
not be a sign of British leadership and
not allow us to keep ourselves and
indeed our allies safe so so the amount
of money that's needed right now for to
increase fence spending is minimal it
would actually start Rising
or so on on that commitment the funding
would really start rising in 2025 so
there would be time to deal with the
cost of living crisis that we have now
and to use what her commitments
currently are to to address the issues
so obviously her 30 billion pounds of
tax cuts are to not put in place a
National Insurance rise that has you
know only just or about to take place is
to suspend effectively the green levy on
energy bills because I mean that that is
not a let's say a cost to the executive
at the moment it's it's just saying that
we're not going to we're going to
suspend it for now but try and give
people uh a better you know to face
their bills but she's also said that
they are within the treasury's envelope
the 30 billion pounds they are within
the Headroom that she could use to
address some of the cost of living
crisis and I think you know that that is
right she's also said that the
alternative which is to win to keep this
very very heavy tax burden on people as
the oecd has said would have a
contractual effect on our economy in
fact shrink the economy because the real
way the real way we address our debts
and have the money to spend on
government is economic growth it's not
tax and spend it is grow the economy and
but the growth will take some time and
in the meantime she's likely to break
the government's own fiscal rules on
borrow no she's not she's not likely to
break the physical rule she's been very
clear about that and she's already said
there is Headroom within that envelope
and I think she has said that within
three years debt will start falling as a
percentage of GDP and that is the
commitment she will make but if we don't
grow the economy we simply won't have
the tax receipts uh even at the current
tax levels to fund what we need and I
think people seem to think that it's
very simple you just simply raise a tax
pay off the debt and go back that's tax
and spend economics the economics I'm
interested in is how do we stimulate
growth so cutting the right taxes like
not proceed with corporation tax Rises
helps us grow I mean when Rishi was a
Chancellor he cut entrepreneurial's
relief he cut the relief that we give to
our entrepreneurs who've invested in
this country invested in businesses and
that's not a way to to to create either
wealth or indeed growth okay you talk
about authenticity but listross was a
liberal Democrat which is now obviously
a Tory she was a remainer now she's a
brexiteer so is that being authentic
yeah I think it's because she's been
very honest that's you know she's been
you know as she's gone through life as
many young people might go through live
I think she's developed I think people
develop through life everyone uh you
know many of the people that are your
journalists are indeed your commentators
some of them even some of them in the
mainstream media some have started lives
as a communist and then I have sort of
rabbit Tories so I think what I would
say is people go on Journeys politically
because of their upbringing and and
their influence of their parents and all
things you know she she often said that
when she was seven her her parents who
were left-wing took her to CND marches
you know doesn't make her a rabid CND
it's just part of the experience of
growing up and I think that's important
that we recognize people develop all the
way through their lives and that's not
about being inconsistent but I think
what I can tell you having sat next to
in the cabinet is that what you see is
what you get and something else that's
really important she's actually
incredibly experienced in government you
know she is the only candidate that did
nearly two years in the treasury as the
chief Secretary of the Treasury that's
the the number two position it attends
cabinets incredibly important it's the
bookkeeper of the country she did that
job in the treasury she was then
international trade and negotiated trade
deals and now she's been a foreign
secretary that's a broad experience that
I'm afraid Rishi doesn't have yes he's
been you know in the Chancery but that's
okay that doesn't have that broad
experience well let's talk about Rishi
soon out because Nadine Doris the
culture secretary was on the show
yesterday and she suggested that he was
involved in a coup to remove Boris
Johnson is that how you see it I'm I I'm
not coming here to to attack the other
candidate my view is I Liz can sell
herself on her qualities I think she has
many qualities I don't I don't think you
know we're going to get into we don't
want this Blue on Blue I'm not sitting
here poking sticks at Rishi Rishi Suna
is a very clever very capable member of
the cabinet or was a member of the
cabinet he he is you know he is you know
any government would be you know pleased
to have him in the government but but
fundamentally you know I'm here to say
well I think Liz trust is the best
candidate well you say you're not going
to criticize the chance on it but you've
been very critical of the chancellor in
the papers haven't you you talked about
him walking out you said that you didn't
have the luxury of walking out well I
said ministers don't some ministers
don't have the luxury of walking out I
mean if you actually look if you look at
that article I was asked why I didn't
resign and I said some ministers don't
have the luxury of resigning because
fundamentally we have duties and
obligations you know I have myself and
the Home Secretary for example we sign
warrants we we have a we have a role in
the operational delivery of defending
this nation she does warrants Etc I I
have to take responsibility in
operational authorities and decisions
around our forces around the world so I
can't just sort of
junk it all in and walk out of water no
I didn't want Boris Johnson to go I
wouldn't have uh thought that was the
way to do it but I also made clear and I
made a tweet at the time that for those
colleagues who do want to to express
their lack of confidence in the
government there's a very simple way of
doing that there was going to be a 1922
a vote predicted on the Monday the next
week a couple of days after Rishi
resigned and they could have done it
that way they could have voted the Prime
Minister through confidence in the party
and you could have done it that's the
mechanism he said he said he couldn't
stay a moment longer while there was a
significant difference over Economic
Policy you say he was wrong to go no I I
just don't think triggering cabinet
ministers walking out at a time of a
crisis is the right course of action
there were other mechanisms to do what
they wanted if they if Richard Sherman
didn't want the prime minister to be
prime minister there were other
mechanisms to do that and that goes for
all the other ministers I felt but you
know you know he made his choices he
reconciles himself with that you know I
I'm there to the end my job until I'm
replaced by a defense secretary and it's
perfectly legitimate that Prime
Ministers pick and choose their cabinet
I have that obligation not just to my
leader but also to the the men and women
under under the forces command does he
really leave the country in the Lurch I
mean another Chancellor was appointed
pretty much immediately well look you
know let's look at that Friday afternoon
I think it was a Friday what are the
markets had crashed what if there's a
what if the Home Secretary had done that
there was a terrorist attack you know
what what would the public think they
would never forgive us for that so I
just took the view my judgment was you
know well first of all I didn't want the
prime minister to go but but if I had
been in that position I think there was
another mechanism of doing it that was a
1922 procedures the following week I
don't think people needed to walk out uh
the public would would see that as a
government not thinking about the job in
hand and I think you know there were
there were many other opportunities if
they wanted to do it in a different way
you talk about economic emergencies many
would say we're going through one now
with the cost of living crisis we
learned yesterday new estimates for
energy Bills going to go even higher
than predicted a size 3 850 pounds a
year by January the current package just
isn't sufficient is it more has to be
done well I think we all recognize we've
got to try and do you know all of us do
our bit you know government has control
over some things like the like the levy
the the the the environmental sort of
precept that Liz trust has said she was
spent would suspend we all have a a role
in what makes a big difference you know
but but there's also going to be a
return on people's energy bills uh that
the current government has helped
deliver and including uh the chancellor
there's going to be a return I think
it's being set out today how people are
going to get money off their energy bill
I think that's just 400 pounds but but
you know for 400 pounds a year ago was a
lot of money I mean it is it is a
contribution that the government can
make obviously get making sure that we
unlock investment into uh alternative
energy sources is incredibly important
for the medium and the long term so this
is not just a short-term problem we're
gonna have to deal with this in the
medium term and I think you know that I
I supported uh the government's plan and
Rishi cnx plan to actually put uh you
know the energy tax the the windfall tax
on earlier and I think you know that
that is the right place to go if if the
energy companies aren't investing in UK
capabilities so I think we are doing our
bit to raise money from the Energy
company is to try and alleviate the
pressure of course the problem is Energy
prices are going up and up and up and up
there are other measures that we're all
going to have to get involved in and I
notice countries in Europe already doing
it about energy saving measures what we
can what steps can we all take at home
to try and reduce our energy that is
that has got to be something we've all
got to contribute to but there is a
reality here which is a very difficult
problem for us all which is it is an
energy crisis uh born out of things like
the war in Ukraine around the world
where we have very little control over
it's why it's important that we see off
people like Putin that we make sure we
equip our Armed Forces to give the world
that stability and security because
without that security we will see more
of these problems and that's a long-term
aim but for now people need money should
the windfall tax be increased more money
be gained from the windfall tax we saw
big profits yesterday from sort of
energy companies first of first of all
the windfall tax itself is a is a
percentage so so if if they get more and
more money they're going to get more and
more they're going to be paying more and
more tax so so thing you will see an
increase in receipts from that tax as
they make more profits themselves I
think that is that is really important
we understand that I think what we need
to make sure is that we we constantly
explore the measures for the cost of
living but but look it's not just in in
energy it's going to be in food you know
there is global insecurity whether that
is in Ukraine or whether that's in the
Pacific
we're all connected today we're all
we're all Linked In This World uh covid
has been a global pandemic that we are
all dealing with the shock of it that
does mean there aren't any magic wants
it means that we all have to invest in
our resilience we have to invest in our
diversity of a supply you know we are
very lucky in Britain and while we are
going to face some very tough bills
energy bills in the future we are not
dependent on Russian gas like many
European countries who have no choices
I want to I want to talk very quickly
about your brief about defense because
as Stephen lovegrove the UK's National
Security advisor has warned in the last
few days that the West risks an
initiation of nuclear conflict with
China or Russia because of a breakdown
of communication with two countries do
you agree with him well I went to Moscow
as trust to speak to our counterparts
just before this war we keep lines of
communications open uh I have met with a
Chinese Ambassador about a year and a
half ago and I'm you know he's right
that it's always important to talk to
countries even if you find it difficult
or distasteful or indeed you know it is
a challenge because there's a conflict
in Ukraine but I think fundamentally
that is not always the the real
component of why security is can be
imperiled it is often the intention of
the other country you know President
Putin has defied all logic in what he
has done in Ukraine everyone from his
friends to his adversaries advised not
to do it from presidents to Prime
Ministers we we saw the legendary sort
of marathon phone calls the president
mackerel to Putin and he still did it
and that that's very hard because you
know when when someone just doesn't want
to listen to reason uh sadly that you
know you end up in a very difficult
position that's where we are in Ukraine
a proper War uh you know the Russians
are failing at the moment on the ground
in many areas you know they've gone
Putin's plan A B and C has failed and he
remain looked to plan D
um but you know it doesn't matter how
many times you say them it's not the
right thing to do you cut you can't just
get somewhere the warm words sometimes
you need warm words and I'm afraid some
hard power alongside it and on the
subject of Ukraine Liz trust back in
February said she supported individuals
that wanted to go and fight there was
that a misstep on the world stage I
think what she was saying is it is a
very noble cause right I mean this is a
fascist State invading Ukraine I mean
the what the behavior of President Putin
uh you know where 2.5 million ukrainians
have been deported to Russia through
filtration camps where the war crimes
been committed where rapes and and
pillaging effectively is going on where
where you know random civilian parts of
towns are being hit by missiles it is a
noble cause and I think what she was
saying is all of us feel that in this
country all of us look at our television
screens whether we're from the labor
party the conservative party or even the
SNP in our house and think this wrong
this is brutal this is on our doorstep I
think that's what you're saying okay Ben
Wallace thanks very much indeed for your
time and we did know what you said about
uh child care for military families